[Music]
so
[Music]
hello i'm fuli batibo this is counting
the cast on al jazeera you look at the
world of business and economics this
week europe threatened with gas
shortages and looks for alternatives to
supplies from russia can african nations
fill the energy gap
also this week as the war in ukraine
rattles the global economy could it lead
to a change in the order of the
financial world and what's the impact on
nations worldwide both rich and poor
and breaking through so-called walled
gardens the european union agrees to
curb the dominance of technology
companies but will the new regulations
allow fair competition on the internet
and can they set a global standard
thank you for joining us the war in
ukraine is squeezing russian gas
supplies to europe eu countries want to
reduce their dependence on moscow and
are pulling out all the stops to find
alternative supplies africa has a wealth
of natural gas reserves and could fill
the gap many european countries are
exploring whether the continent could be
part of the energy solution they
desperately need
many african countries are eyeing the
opportunity and have expressed their
interest in increasing supplies to
europe europe imported about 108 billion
cubic meters of lng from africa in 2019
over 12 billion of which came from
nigeria the nation has recently approved
a roadmap to construct a multi-billion
trans-saharan gas pipeline known as
nigal the project will run through niger
and algeria and connects to europe's
existing network
now pipelines that transport gas from
africa to europe are mainly located in
north africa the magrib europe gas
pipeline in algeria transfers natural
gas to spain and portugal through
morocco but supplies have been disrupted
because of political tensions between
algiers and rabat the u.s secretary of
state is sought to have discussed the
reopening of the pipeline during his
recent visit to both countries
the magda's pipeline links algeria
directly to spain the african nation is
estimated to have exported
255 million cubic meters of gas to spain
in 2020. the transmitted pipeline
connects algeria to italy through
tunisia algeria is italy's second
largest gas exporter after russia
the green stream submarine pipelines run
from western libya to the island of
sicily in italy
but that makes up just 2.5 percent of
overall italian daily demand
now the shift in global energy markets
raises questions about how countries can
meet their climate goals
while europe says it wants to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 55
percent by 2030 and make the transition
to green energy alternatives activists
have pushed for a hold to african gas
investments an effort that forced
foreign companies to rethink their
operations on the continent
well to find out more about africa's gas
potential i'm now joined by kola karim
the group managing director of shoreline
energy international and an african
energy chamber advisory board member he
joins us from london mr karim thank you
very much for being with us on counting
the cost many african countries have
expressed interest in increasing gas
supplies to europe but do they have the
capacity to do this
they do have by way of reserves uh if
you look at a country like nigeria with
210 tcf of natural gas reserves you look
at muslim beef with over 100 tcf of
natural gas reserves so it's established
that the reserve's there but what is
more important is the capital to build
the infrastructure to actually fill and
bridge that gap and that's what's
missing today so it's a difficult one
because with decarbonization capital
is scarce and africa is always the last
point of core
huge capital is going to look at for
such infrastructure so
missing middle is capital is required to
bridge that gap but the reserves are
there because of the potentials
all these african countries are sitting
on so
there's the infrastructure challenge
challenge as you say and then the
funding of course also where will it
come from
look the true position is this right now
i think this the shifting policy from
what has happened between russia and
ukraine is actually pointing capital and
serious investors who are now forced to
look for alternatives with the
announcement and pronouncement by the eu
cutting natural gas imports and oil
imports from russia looking for
alternate sources and africa hopefully
should be the natural choice so the
capital should be coming from that
market right so then how quickly do you
expect the gas to start flowing north
after years of under investment
look it is also a difficult one there is
gas flowing already from algeria the
potential hookup is the trans-saharan
gas which is looking at hooking nigeria
up and connecting that to algeria with
potentials of more exports into europe
right another hopefully 30 billion cubic
meter but the true thing is
how long is it going to take to build
that infrastructure and that's the
elephant in the room indeed and i was
going to ask you about that the
trans-saharan pipeline niger nigeria and
algeria have said they've agreed a road
map but is this just a pipe dream do you
think how challenging is it going to be
to get this project going
you know the true position is
it's going to be challenging because of
the recent security problems we've had
in the sale
now but the true thing is with
commitments and the zeal from the
europeans looking for alternate sources
the reality is assured
we're talking about 13 to 15 billion
dollars of capital to be spent on this
project that's a lot of money but it's
not insurmountable capital that cannot
be found because the european buyers the
european market are now forced looking
for alternative source of energy and
africa naturally by proximity of of
distance is the natural choice yeah you
talked about the security concerns and
they have been security concerns over
the years especially in a country like
nigeria for example which has struggled
with armed groups and also disagreements
over the the the fair distribution of
the oil wealth do you think those
security concerns have been addressed to
allow you know this project to go ahead
the security concerns as it pertains to
nigeria and the sahel is an ongoing
issue that will and it's been addressed
on a daily basis it's not going to be an
easy task right the biggest problem has
been poverty if you look at all the
trouble spots in in in sub-saharan
africa the biggest problem is poverty
right and if our people and the people
in these areas are prosperous i'm sure
we'll see
far reduced incursions and problems so i
think governments are focusing on it and
trying to address it it's not going to
be an easy task but the focus is trying
to get something done right there's a
poverty issue and then there are the
politics also we saw the u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken travel to
algeria and morocco this week there's a
question of course of opening up the gas
pipeline from algeria to europe via
morocco which had been shut down last
year after algeria suspended ties with
morocco because of the issue of of
western sahara how
you know how do you see that going
forward is is that issue likely to be
resolved can the u.s help bring these
two countries together you know the true
position of what we see reality of
global politics is when the western
nations have a problem they always try
and they always find a way
in getting things resolved so you will
see the situation in between morocco and
algeria will resolve itself because of
it necessitates flow of gas into the
european markets to elevate the
potential problems that we're seeing
today look
russia exports over 300 million cubic
meters a day
into the european union
that's about 150 billion cubic meters a
year that's huge
an example the largest economy in europe
germany that's 55
of their gas imports if you disrupt
you're disrupting the economy of the
strongest european nation so it's not
going to be an easy task and emergency
position is what has been put in place
in finding adequate replacement to
support if there's going to be a shift
but right now the focus and policy
that's been pronounced is reduction in
importation from russia and that's gap
the gap potential that's got to be
filled thank you so much very
interesting to talk to you about this
kola kareem managing director of
shoreline energy international thank you
for being on counting the cost
thank you
and ukraine's president has asked qatar
and other gas rich nations to produce
more to counter what he called the
russian threat to use energy as a weapon
vladimir zelinski made the plea here in
doha while speaking to leaders at the
doha forum zelensky also warned that no
country is immune to the impact of the
russian invasion of his country citing
the hike in food prices russia is the
world's largest exporter of wheat and
ukraine is the fifth largest but the
global disruption to global supplies
goes beyond oil and grains the flow of
many metals is also at risk
so
should the world be worried about the
impact of economic deprivations that
could be caused by the war in ukraine
well my colleague nick clark put this
and other questions to kelly kraft the
former u.s permanent representative to
the united nations he spoke to her at
the doha forum
you know i think in the united states
there's this saying that what happens in
vegas stays in vegas
and that is no longer the case what
happens in ukraine affects the entire
world and that's why we are here at the
doha forum i mean the entire the topic
has really been around ukraine russia
and i look at this in a way from a
security council standpoint and from a
general assembly standpoint in the fact
that
within the security council we have seen
russia be able to veto their own
punishment their own reprimand
but then you have the general assembly
and i think that's really shown a
spotlight on the fact that every country
has their has an equal vote there are no
vetoes but it also allowed us to see the
african
countries and who abstained who vote the
one that voted with russia
and
it kind of shows us that there are
winners and losers
if you think about it
with russia with with the especially
with the way that russia has gone into
several of the countries in africa with
gold with their wagner group you know
protecting the gold mines
with the fact that they're looking at
the rare earth minerals in in congo or
diamonds and so you you can see the
winners and the losers you can see some
of these countries within africa whose
leadership are really very short-sighted
and they're looking at short-term gain
instead of long-term gain and building
up their country because this is a
country this is a continent of the most
of the most youth of the youngest
right and we're losing our focus on
building up future generations because
it is those countries that will be
deeply affected because the knock-on
effect commodity prices for example and
the price of food
that's going to have a huge issue in
places like yemen and across the
continent across the continent of africa
well and you look in just from this
previous panel you look at yemen and
it's unfortunate that we're all focused
on ukraine russia but yet we still we do
have this one of the world's worst
famine in yemen and yemen is directly
affected because of with the world food
program and all of the different
humanitarian resources wheat being the
main commodity there so we're seeing
that not only affect
the continent of africa but we're seeing
that in yemen also
ukraine's economy is also taking a
severe hit how can how can it cope in
the meantime while the conflict is going
on and what about moving forward as
things perhaps settle down at some point
in the coming months
what help will be provided to ukraine
you know if you look at the the
industries or or just the the
agriculture business in ukraine and for
that matter
the russian farmers that were fed
disinformation most of them don't even
know what's really occurred
so we really we need to be building up
now we need to be helping the
agricultural industry in ukraine the
industries that
really had the most exports because
that's where they're going to need to
rebuild their country is starting with
the basics just the basic needs
which are going to be their their export
market right there has been this talk of
a kind of collective effort to deal with
situations like this this freedom fund
what do you make of that as a as a way
forward to try and deal with these kind
of situations you know i think the
freedom fund is very important but we
need to remember we need to be able to
utilize the people within ukraine we
need to be able to build up their
economy by also
giving these very people the jobs to
rebuild when this fund is activated
there's been this this great collective
effort to put sanctions on russia do you
think
we've gone far enough
in my personal opinion
in the security council whenever we
spoke about sanctions they didn't mean a
thing to russia and if you look at the
way our our currency is today with our
cryptocurrency and other forms of
currency
the dollar is not that powerful
so sanctions really
being placed on russia they're you know
they're no longer asking for
us dollars because they can work around
there's lots of loopholes we need to
figure out the loopholes and look at
that area
that's how we're going to have these
sanctions that work but the problem is
of course there's no way of putting the
the screws on russia or on putin
without implicating
and having a
serious effect on the global economy how
do you get around that
we needed to be building up our economy
if you want to look at the united states
and the administration that i served
candidate trump at the point at that
time talked about the importance of
building up our industry within our
country
because of china and then when he was
you know president trump he acted upon
that
we need to continue speak about china
for a second we need to continue to
build up our country so that we're not
dependent
you know here we are now energy
dependent
when we were energy independent
we were producing our oil we had you
know keystone pipeline instead we
immediately relieved sanctions on gas
prom on the
pipeline in germany
why would we do that when we can be
energy independent in our own country
let's just hope that next year that
we're all not sitting here and we're not
discussing
china taiwan
now giant technology companies are not
only getting bigger they've already
eclipsed major oil firms they've also
made huge earnings an idea of just how
lucrative their business is apple's
profit alone for the past year was more
than the yearly profit of eight major
companies combined and they include
disney and mcdonald's but just a handful
of tech companies are dominating the
market well now the european union aims
to curb their power by agreeing
far-reaching rules that could allow
smaller companies to flourish
some have said it it was a bit like the
wild west it was a bit in their hands
we have regained power because we're
political authorities
we said to them of course you are
welcome in this space that represents
the digital internal market
but these are our rules
the legislation is the eu's biggest
overhaul of laws governing big tech
operations in more than two decades it
requires platforms to open up access to
their spaces to third parties or other
businesses this means users of the
whatsapp messaging service for example
could text a friend using a different
service and tech giants wouldn't be
allowed to rank their own products or
services higher than those of others in
search results software or apps such as
web browsers can't be installed by
default and companies won't be able to
combine users personal data from
different platforms for targeted ads
unless explicit consent is given among
many other rules repeat violations of
the regulation could result in fines of
up to 20 percent of a company's global
annual revenue and companies could be
temporarily banned from conducting
mergers and accusations
the digital market act will apply to
what the eu calls gatekeepers those are
companies with a market value of more
than 83 billion dollars and with at
least 45 million monthly users or 10 000
business users in the eu the firms must
also have a core platform service like a
social media a search engine provider or
an app store the group includes alphabet
the owner of google youtube amazon apple
microsoft and meta apple has raised
concerns about privacy and security
vulnerabilities for its users while
google said some parts of the rules
could affect innovation the digital
market act came hours before the u.s and
the eu agreed a provisional deal on
cross-border data transfers president
joe biden says the pact would facilitate
more than seven trillion dollars in
economic relationships with the eu
well to discuss all this i'm now joined
from saint galen university in
switzerland by simon evnet he's a
professor of international trade and
economic development at st galen
university and he's also an expert in
competition laws thank you very much mr
evnet for being with us on counting the
cast so what do you make of this these
new rules will they ensure fair
competition and more choice for users
these rules will certainly shift the
competitive landscape in favor of the
smaller medium-sized firms away from the
big digital behemoths whether this
translates into much benefit for
consumers will depend critically on
whether those small or medium-sized
firms use that competitive space to
introduce new innovative services uh
which
expand choice and deliver benefits i
think that's the key question right and
so a key aim of the reform is to prevent
tech giants uh from abusing their market
position to harm smaller rivals but what
will this mean for those big tech giants
how will it affect their business model
and and will it mean less profits for
them
the big tech giants differ considerably
in their business models this
legislation has been written in a way to
target eight different types of uh
digital activity commercial activity and
in each of them it's pretty uh clear
that the
implementation of this if it's
faithfully implemented is likely to
reduce the profitability of the bigger
uh bigger players there are a lot a
number of constraints that are that they
will be under for example uh
operators of platforms will not be able
to force sellers on those platforms to
have to use their uh financial payment
systems so these types of restrictions
are going to be put in place and will
widen choice for buyers and for sellers
at the expense of the big players right
there are concerns that the laws target
american companies unfairly
and that it could affect jobs in the u.s
do you think those concerns are
justified
i think the the the rules have been
written in a way that if a firm becomes
larger than certain specified limits
then they're they fall within the reach
but it should be said that there are
chinese firms as well as american firms
which will uh become so-called
gatekeepers in under these laws and be
subject to these tougher disciplines so
i don't necessarily see it as being
inherent or automatically anti-american
firms but the truth the truth is most of
the most successful
companies in western markets in the
digital space are americans so any large
company which has been successful is
likely to get wrapped into these rules
and many of them are americans so you
can understand where the criticism comes
from right and so what will be the
challenges implementing these new rules
these new measures do you see companies
trying to diminish the law's impact in
the courts for example
the companies will have many options in
terms of how they react to this
particular legislation one one option
will be to challenge whether or not a
company is designated as a gatekeeper
which is what you need to be designated
to fall under the provisions in this
particular law so the first thing the
giants will do i think will be to
contest whether they're designated as
gatekeepers and then if the european
commission comes after them subsequently
with enforcement actions those will get
contested as well so i think yes the
lawyers will be very busy yeah are they
concerns about privacy and innovation as
some tech firms have suggested
so the big tech firms have suggested
that innovation could be diminished
and there the the argument i think they
have some merit in saying this the
european commission has um conceded that
point but the counter argument is that
the additional innovation from the small
and medium-sized firms will cat will um
offer benefits to consumers so that's
the trade-off which is being taken there
on privacy please note and it's
important for your viewers to know this
that uh privacy is not the subject of
this legislation okay privacy will be
the subject of another piece of
legislation the european commission is
going to bring forward okay interesting
that you you mentioned that now we
talked about users briefly uh how are
they going to be affected but also not
just the users the advertisers how are
they going to be impacted by these new
laws
well users will probably have more
choice in terms of different services
being offered on platforms so that will
be a step forward uh but the advertisers
i think they're the message is mixed the
good news for them is that they will be
able to get much more information about
the effectiveness of their advertising
out of the big digital firms the bad
news is that to the extent uh that um
that these platforms become less
attractive because other firms are
rising up and competing against them
then you may end up getting reaching
fewer consumers so for the advertisers i
think the message or the outcome is
likely to be mixed okay now this is the
eu's largest uh overhaul of laws
governing uh the way tech giants operate
do you think it cements europe's
leadership
role here as the most assertive
regulator of big tech and do you see
this being adopted globally
so there's two things there first the eu
has taken a lead on digital regulation
but so has china in terms of its own
domestic market
it's not clear to me who wins that horse
race but both of them have demonstrated
that they have a lot of teeth and
they're willing to use it the second um
the the second point sorry please
remember what was your success is it
going to be adopted globally you think
ah yeah absolutely thank you for that
yes the brussels effect uh will probably
apply that's that's the
effect whereby brussels moves and other
countries copy i think we will see some
emulation of this and possibly even in
the united states as well thank you so
much for talking to us about this simon
events professor of trade and economic
development at st galen university thank
you very much for being with us on
counting the cost
thank you
thank you very much
and that is our show for this week get
in touch with us by tweeting me at fully
bar aje and do use the hashtag ajctc
when you do or drop us an email counting
the costs at aljazeera.net is our
address
but there's more for you online at al
jazeera.com ctc that will take you
straight to our page which has
individual reports links and entire
episodes for you to catch up on
that's it for this edition of counting
the cost i'm fully battybo from the
whole team here in doha thank you for
watching the news on al jazeera is next
you